okay welcome back everybody all right so
today we're going to talk about Fourier
series and we're gonna build up two
Fourier transforms and representing
functions in terms of orthogonal
function spaces so a couple of things I
want to do first are the following I
want to talk about the kinds of
additional PDEs that we could think
about based on what we know now that are
either gonna be on homework 3 or on the
midterm okay so something that'll
definitely be on the homework is to
derive Laplace's equation on a disk okay
the basic idea here is that you can take
and write down x equals our coast theta
y equals R sine theta and you can derive
a 2-d Laplace's equation purely in polar
coordinates RN theta and you could solve
this Laplace's equation on a disk if you
had the temperature distribution and
some fixed radius and temperature okay
so deriving the 2d Laplace's equation I
mean you can google this so you know
what the right answer is you can Google
like what is 2d Laplace's equation in
polar coordinates but I want you to
derive it from the 2d Cartesian
Laplace's equation with partials and
this expression and then I might ask you
to solve this problem so the Laplace's
equation in polar coordinates with a
boundary condition so what would be the
equilibrium temperature distribution
inside of a disc with this boundary
condition you would use separation of
variables that you would do it in polar
coordinates now okay that's the kind of
thing I might ask other kinds of things
I might ask would be looking back at the
rectangular thermal equilibrium problem
so again we're dealing
applause this equation and we had some
boundary conditions some temperature on
the left side and then zero zero zero
equals u equals u equals u what would be
a simple way of changing this problem up
what are some other boundary conditions
that we have for heat equations or for
Laplace equations insulated so an easy
way to change this problem is to have
insulated top and bottom okay that's
another kind of question that I would
either ask on the 3rd homework or on the
midterm exam so you would essentially
rework this exact problem but with
insulated boundary conditions I actually
think it was easier this way something
like that was easier okay that's another
kind of equation that I might ask you I
might also give you a guitar guitar
string question so essentially you have
this guitar string you pluck it and you
have certain differential equation u TT
equals u X X plus you know there's some
constant here and I might have you solve
this equation using separation of
variables okay so separation of
variables Laplace's equation different
coordinate systems different boundary
conditions are all fair game if I gave
you something like this where it was a
new type of physics that I had never
told you about before then I would be
obligated to tell you the equation and
the boundary conditions that I expect
you to use so it doesn't really matter
what the physics is you would get a
system of equations and the physics
would only help you interpret you know
what is physically reasonable or not
okay there's of course also going to be
complex analysis and integrals and all
kinds of other stuff on the exam ok this
one's gonna be a little more difficult
than the exams in last quarter possibly
because I'm trying to get you ready for
the qualifying exams and so I want you
to be solving more real-world problems
okay these are all the kinds of problems
you would actually solve in research and
that's what you need to be able to do
I'm on calls okay any questions about
this this is the last I'm gonna talk
about midterm before the midterm I
haven't written the midterm yeah
okay how many of you feel moderately
prepared for the midterm or more greater
than or equal to moderate how many of
you feel less than moderate we prepared
okay well there's a few days left things
I would do I would go over the basic
things that you know about complex
analysis and complex integrals you
should be able to deal with complex
variables and complex numbers you should
be able to take like complex number to
some power or log of a complex number of
things like that you should be able to
do Taylor series with complex numbers in
them and you should be able to take
complex integrals contour integrals and
use things like Koshi integral formula
Koshi
core soft here and things like that to
change your integrals and do what you
need to do and then we'll have some kind
of peas on the exam okay great
so that's it for for midterm stuff okay
so the next three or four lectures are
going to be about Fourier series and
Fourier transforms and I'm going to
start off using the Fourier series as
kind of an aside so we've been moving
ahead in complex variables and then in
partial differential equations now we're
going to talk a little bit about how we
represent functions in general okay so
when I have differential equations like
UT equals alpha squared u X X or u TT
equals u xx or u xx plus uy y equals 0
right if I have any of these complex any
of these partial differential equations
the basic idea is that U is some
function right the solution of my
partial differential equation is a
function it's a function of time and
space time and space or just two spatial
variables okay
so U as a function of some variables and
what we would like to know is how what
are some alternative ways of
representing functions in general ok
what we have our
you know we represent functions in some
coordinate system so we represent
functions and some kind of a coordinate
system so what are your favorite
coordinate systems that you use all the
time okay
Cartesian right so x and y what are some
other ones polar R and theta some other
ones spherical R Phi and theta some
other ones sorry quarter nians we'll
just skip that one cylindrical and so on
so there's lots of specialized
coordinate systems that we use to write
equations and why do we choose some of
these over other over other coordinate
systems okay ease of representation of
the equations ease of computation of the
equations maybe sometimes when I write
down my physics in these coordinate
systems maybe some of the variables drop
out when would that happen when would I
have variables just drop out of an
equation when it's symmetric in some way
if there's some kind of a symmetry right
so for example well there's tons and
tons of examples right like gravitation
is symmetric
you know it only depends on the radius
it doesn't depend on either of the other
two variables okay and if I have a
reduction in the number of variables
then I have a reduction in the
complexity of my solution okay so this
is essentially called dimensionality
reduction or symmetry reduction and it's
bate it's it's been one of the most
powerful tools used in physics since
physics and math were invented people
were taking complicated problems writing
them in funny coordinate systems so that
they simplified and then solving the
those weird coordinate systems yeah so
Fourier transforms Laplace transforms
are no different they're just a new
coordinate system where we can write our
function where the physics the equations
and the solutions simplify okay so
Fourier and Laplace they're basically
very similar so Fourier transforms allow
us to write our functions in a new
coordinate system and they allow us to
write our functions in a new coordinate
system where they become dramatically
simpler
and we're going to be writing these in
terms of sines and cosines so I'm gonna
talk more about this later we're gonna
get a clearer picture of what I mean but
what I want to do is build this up with
a lot of examples and a little bit of
theory to motivate why we care about
Fourier series and Fourier transforms in
the first place
okay so how many of you have seen for a
series before Fourier transforms okay
how many I've never seen one or either
okay good
so Fourier series are great what they do
is they allow us to take most functions
that we care about and write them as an
infinite sum of sine waves of higher and
higher frequencies okay so if our
function f of X is two pi periodic we're
gonna break all of these conditions
later and piecewise smooth so what does
it mean for a function to be two pi
periodic just means it repeats after
every 2 pi ok so if I have X and f of X
I can do anything I want between 0 & 2
pi but at 0 and 2 pi my function better
have the same value and it better repeat
every 2 pi forever okay so basically
that means the f of X plus 2 pi equals f
of X for every single X you can name for
all X okay so if f is 2 pi periodic and
it's piecewise smooth so this thing can
even be nasty it can have
it can even have jumps as long as it
repeats every 4pi okay so this thing can
be piecewise discontinuous then we're
going to be able to write f as this
infinite sum of sine waves of higher and
higher frequencies okay then f of X our
function we're gonna say that this
almost exactly equals our Fourier series
function so this new function is my
Fourier series and it basically equals
my function and that equals some
constant plus an infinite series for all
integers N equals 1 to 3 up to infinity
of a and coasts and X plus B and sign
and X okay a N and B and then a naught
are just numbers okay and a N and B n
have their own formulas for how we get
them okay so a n is equal to 1 over pi
integral minus PI to PI of f of X coasts
and xdx and BN equals 1 over pi integral
minus PI to PI of f of X sine NX DX okay
I'll let this just sink in for a little
bit maybe I should box this is pretty
important
I didn't have to integrate from minus PI
to PI that's just a choice I made I
could have integrated from zero to two
pi or one to one plus two pi or 14 to 14
plus 2 pi it doesn't matter since two pi
periodic so any domain that is length 2
pi and continuous in X is a fine
integration bound ok I'm just choosing
minus PI to PI I'm choosing this for a
reason that'll become clear later which
is minus PI to PI allows me to evaluate
whether or not my function is even or
odd ok if I integrate from 0 to 2 pi
it's not super clear if this function is
even or odd until I look at what happens
from minus PI to PI and then I can see
if it's symmetric or anti-symmetric so
minus PI to PI is kind of conventional
as what a lot of people do you're gonna
see me jumping back and forth from minus
PI to PI to 0 to 2 pi it doesn't matter
ok so the basic idea is that if my
function f is reasonably well behaved
then I can represent it as a sum of
sines and cosines and the frequencies of
these sines and cosines start at you
know frequency 1 and they go all the way
up to frequency infinity and I have to
add up all of these things and then I
get an almost perfect representation in
my function ok so
I've been going back and forth about
what the right order to explain things
is because I don't want to confuse you
before you have the right foundation to
know more about Fourier series but I
also want to tell you the full story
okay so I think I'm going to tell you
the full story first this function f of
X equals f of you know my Fourier series
f of X this is only they're not strictly
speaking equal they're kind of equal
okay and I'm going to tell you what kind
of equal means so these are equal in in
a norm that I define on my function
spaces so these are equal in an integral
sense which means that the integral of
so f of X minus my Fourier series of X
there's something called a two norm on
functions how many of you have some
basic idea about have two norm on a
function is okay I want to explain this
to you this is going to become super
important it's not complicated at all
it's really really simple so just like
we have vectors and we can define the
distance of vectors right what we do is
we add up the squares of the sum of the
sum of the squares of the component
differences and then take the square
roots that's the norm of a vector well
I'm telling you that all of these
functions are living in an infinite
dimensional vector space and so they
also have a norm a difference between
these two these two vectors every
function has a length and the difference
between two functions also has a length
and if the distance between these two
functions is zero then we say that
they're basically the same function and
would the way we define that distance
as we say well this is equal to the
integral over the domain I care about
minus PI to PI of this function squared
of f minus my Fourier series squared DX
and this equals zero that's what I mean
by these two functions being equal what
I mean is that these two functions are
infinitesimally close to each other in
function space for all intents and
purposes in this in this inner product
in this norm they're zero distance apart
they're the same function now what that
means is that if I have some function
now why am I making all of this fuss
about infinite dimensional vector spaces
why don't I just say that the functions
are equal at all points X because this
basically would only be true if my
functions were equal at all points X
right okay so let's say that I have my
okay so let's say that this is my
function that's two pi periodic so if
this function C this Fourier series has
to be basically the same at all of the
points in my domain but at this
discontinuity here it doesn't know which
point to be so something crazy happens
right there in my Fourier series this
red curve is my Fourier series and so as
long as this discontinuity only happens
at a few places
this difference still only integrates up
to two zero this doesn't happen over any
appreciable DX
so what this means is that my function
and my Fourier series agree at every
point where my function is smooth over
the entire domain and it's gonna
disagree at all points where F is
discontinuous but as long as I have you
know countably many as long as I have
you know a hundred or a thousand or a
million of these discontinuities as long
as I don't have a whole patch that's
discontinuous then these disagreements
between my Fourier series and my regular
function still add up to zero those
differences are are confined to
infinitesimally X's okay this is a
little bit weird but I want to tell you
the full story so anyway we have this
definition of a length of a function and
these two functions are equal as long as
the length of the distance vector is
also equal to zero okay it's a little
weird we're gonna get some better
intuition for how this works later if
you have any questions please ask there
are other senses of equality the this is
called this is called the L 2 integral
norm this is by far the most used
integral norm in all of physics this is
what you use in quantum mechanics and
general relativity and all kinds of
physics implementing this is the most
common one the L 2 integral norm was
invented to handle functions like this
one that had these finite occasional
nastiness is occurring because you can
still say in what sense my a solution
agrees with the original function as
long as these discontinuities are
relegated to very very small finitely
many you know occurrences so this L 2
integral norm is very nice and smoothing
there are L 1 integral norms L 3 L 4
four-thirds l pi integral norms there's
a whole family a continuum of integral
norms that are each useful in their own
context and there's completely different
norms that don't involve integrals of
functions yeah like in the heat equation
let's say I had two bars this one's hot
and this one's cold and at time five I
bump them up against each other
okay or let's say I take my guitar
string and I pull it back and I let it
go so I have this initial condition
where it starts and then it evolves like
there's other you know so we kind of
approximate things like my finger
plucking a string as discontinuities
that would then impulsively force my
system so we need to be able to that's a
both great questions you need to be able
to handle these in the l2 interval norm
is kind of the most common way of
handling these discontinuities so if I
take this difference and it's a positive
number yeah so when you say that it is
equal to zero does that mean that there
is another discontinuity which has the
opposing sign so that it cancels out
before you know so this discontinuity is
a finite disagreement between these two
that's a real positive disagreement but
it's multiplied by something that we're
taking the limit as it goes to zero so
this is this L - L stands for lebesgue
there is this really smart
I mean spell a big slob esque so this
guy Levesque
was trying to figure out how you
integrate functions that have
discontinuities he was much more
concerned with a different discontinuity
like the Dirac Delta discontinuity where
you have something like a Gaussian but
where its height is infinite and its
width is infinitesimal okay so you take
the limit of a zero variance Gaussian
you get this Delta function and so what
he argued is that you actually can
integrate these functions that might
even be infinite valued over one tiny
tiny location if you so we're used to
adding up our integrals using
horizontally you know vertical
rectangles that we add up horizontally
and he decided why can't I just do it
like a layer cake why can't I add up
vertical slices that are stacked you
know horizontal slices that are stacked
vertically I can add them up that way
and then I can handle this infinite
valued function I can just take the
limit and see if everything cancels and
I get one when I integrate this Delta
function so lebesgue introduced these
different kinds of integrals that handle
a few finite discontinuities this is
called the lebesgue integral and these l
two integrals allow us to handle things
that have discontinuities so this L 2
integral you can do using the normal
Riemann Way and if you add up all of the
differences between these two things if
I look at my distance my you know F
minus F for a series I have something
that zero zero zero zero finite zero
zero zero zero zero and if I add up all
of these little rectangles I get zero
zero and you know five times zero DX is
zero here so as long as I have you know
as long as these really are
discontinuities that happen at a exact x
location then the integral of this error
is still zero because it has zero width
in x0 so we call that
this has no measure on the x-axis if you
tried to measure the width of this Delta
function with a tape measure and have
zero measure
okay so lebesgue was really smart he
came up with this notion of measure
funky integrals to handle
discontinuities and infinite values and
he created this entire family of
integral norms the L P integral norms
and we're going to use the L two for our
functions okay
so just one last thing before we get
into a much more concrete example again
so L two of a comma B this is a notation
that we introduced this means this is an
entire family of functions this is a set
of functions right the real numbers is a
set of numbers the integers is a set of
numbers there's infinitely many of them
this is a set of functions these are a
set of functions that are square
integrable on the domain X inside A to B
so this is a whole family a huge family
of integrals of functions basically
every function that you can name almost
is in this family almost every function
and if I had a function f in this space
of functions then it would satisfy the
property that my integral from A to B of
f of x squared is a finite number so
something is square integral it just
means that it's square integrated
doesn't blow up to infinity
almost every function that is nice and
happy that we're used to thinking of
sines cosines Exponential's all these
functions their square integral on most
domains a good example of a function
that's not square integral integral is f
of X this is a counter example f of X
equals 1 over X on 0 to 2 this is
definitely not square integrable on the
domain 0 to 2 because this would blow up
to infinity right this integral is not
finite
maybe it is actually no it's not
definitely not so this is not square
integrable but a sine a cosine so say
this is a and this is B any function
that's bounded between a and B is square
and interval the only things that aren't
are things that blow up to infinity in a
catastrophic way okay that's enough
function space stuff I want to do some
MATLAB and I want to go back to the
concrete example of a Fourier series so
I gave you a function that's 2pi
periodic now I'm going to generalize
this we're gonna say that they don't
have to be 2pi periodic they could just
be L periodic so this also works for
functions that are L periodic this L is
just a length it's not L like lebesgue
name this is just a length L periodic so
my for my Fourier series is still equal
to some constant plus an infinite sum N
equals 1 to infinity of a constant a n
times coasts but now my coasts has to be
has that period of L ok so these are
going to be harmonics of the 0 to L
length
so these are going to be cosines of 2 pi
n x over L plus BN times sine of 2 pi
and x over L right I have this 2 PI over
L here because I'm saying that my
function is periodic between 0 and L so
my sines and cosines have to start and
stop at 0 and L these have to be the
nodes of my sines and cosines and so
that's why I have this two PI over L
factor here and a n is also pretty
simple it's just 2 over L integral 0 to
L of my function times cos 2 pi and x
over L and BN is 2 over L integral 0 to
L f of X sine of all this stuff 2 pi n x
over L so this should start looking
pretty familiar this is exactly what we
had in the last example in class on
Friday where we had the heat equation
and we had some thermal some temperature
distribution on the right-hand side of
the rectangle f of Y and we were writing
our function in terms of sines of
different harmonics ok so we were
looking at half of this series last time
just the sign half of the series last
time with the heat equation ok so I want
to code this up in MATLAB and give you
some examples of what this looks like ok
these are all things we can do right we
can integrate a function times cosine of
any frequency we like in MATLAB over any
domain we like and we can add up
functions and plot them ok
okay so what we're gonna do
the first thing I'm just gonna create
some function that we're going to
approximate using Fourier series okay so
I'm going to define a DX equals some
small number my length I'm just going to
make it equal to one the X is going to
be DX in X tell okay so I have you know
a DX I have a domain from 0 to L and I
have some spatial variable that goes
into X's up to L and we're going to say
that my function is equal to ones of the
size of X so what does that make my
function 1 f of X equals 1 this is just
a big vector of ones all right I mean we
can just plot this plot x by f1 but what
I want to do now is I want to say that
the first half of f the first half of
the values in F I want to set equal to 0
ok so now this thing steps up from 0 to
1 this is the step function it's a
pretty poor way of drawing this maybe I
can access negative 0.5 to 1 point 5
negative 0.5 to 1.5 probably will work
ok that's my step function yeah
I started it at DX there were two
reasons I want this thing to have length
of 200 not 201 the specter like I just
don't want it to be if it starts at 0
that I have a hard time remembering how
long it is it's always you know and by L
divided by DX plus 1 the other reason I
don't want to start at 0 is because I
would end up double counting 0 because
my function should be 2 pi periodic this
one's not I've totally lied this works
for non periodic functions but if my
function really was 2 pi periodic then I
would have already captured the left
value at x equals 0 because I'm
including x equals L so you don't want
to kind of double count the boundaries
just pick one and include it and don't
include the other one okay all right
that looks good all right so now what
we're gonna do is we're going to build
up our Fourier series and we're going to
start plotting the Fourier series as we
increase the number n ok so our Fourier
series is equal to 0 size of X we're
going to start with just zeros and then
we're going to add you know cosines and
sines of higher and higher frequencies
and see how it converges ok the last
thing I need to do is say that I have
this constant a naught over 2 out front
and a naught is equal to my a naught is
equal to this integral where cosine of 2
pi is 0 x over L where n is 0 and what's
cosine of 0 1 that's 1 for the entire
domain for all of these X's okay so so
that a naught coefficient I get by
taking 2 divided by the length of my
domain times the sum of my thumb
in times a vector of ones of size x
times DX this is just a fancy way of
saying I'm integrating my function x co
sub-zero DX okay so from M equals 1 to
100 maybe I'll just say okay so we start
with this constant our Fourier series is
a naught over 2 plus a bunch of sines
and cosines so for K equals 1 to 100 I'm
going to maybe I'll say N equals 1 to
100 I'll say a K and a N and B N equals
so I'm going to compute my coefficients
a and and BN and then I'm gonna add a n
sine of 2 pi n over L plus BN coast to
PI sine of Oracle ok so what are my
coefficients a and in the end I'm never
gonna remember these and I can't see
them from the board okay 2 over L times
x I'm integrating so I'm going to add up
a bunch of stuff and what am i adding up
okay I'm gonna term wise multiply my
function by what coasts of 2 pi and x
over L right multiplying I'm integrating
f of X with cosine of 2 pi n x over L
for n 1 & 2 & 3 & 4
ok and I better multiply by DX so I
don't want to just add up all these
numbers there's a DX okay and BN is
similar to / L some F dot times sine of
2 pi and X / l dot yeah
okay and the last part is my Fourier
series is gonna be growing I'm going to
add more sine waves to it and so I'm
going to add this current sine wave
which is a N times Coast 2pi n X divided
by L plus BN times sine 2pi and X
divided by L okay I think that'll work
sorry for okay thank you
cool okay good so now we have this
growing function we're gonna add up a
hundred sine waves and I've already
plotted the function that I want and so
now down here I'm going to plot I'm
gonna hold on and plot the function I
have in red dashes let's hope this works
I don't have a backup all right so it
works you can see that my red dash line
almost perfectly captures this black
line it's very very good almost looks
too good it's really really really good
let's say I have ten modes here okay if
I just add up the first ten sines and
cosines this is what I get not perfect
interesting though so the basic idea is
that I can add up more and more sines
and cosines until I build up this shape
and if I add up enough if I add up
infinitely many sines and cosines then
eventually this function will completely
agree except at these discontinuities
and you notice that the weirdest stuff
is happening at the discontinuities it's
happening at the point where you go from
zero to one and you can also think of
the fact that my function is not
periodic
that's another discontinuity okay like
this is just just continuously going
back
down to zero and so I have this other
big discontinuity that's symmetric over
here okay so first all any questions
about this code I should show you the
code is it pretty clear what we're doing
in terms of like there's some formula
for getting A's and B's and every time I
get a new a and B I get a new you know
coefficient times sine plus coefficient
times cosine that I add to my series
this series goes on forever there's some
things I didn't tell you for example why
is it that this approximation just gets
better and better and better the more
and that I include the more modes that I
include I call these sines and cosines
modes why does this approximation just
get better the more sines and cosines
that I include
it's not obvious I'll explain it more
later so let's make a big for loop here
so for N equals 1 to 100 so these are
the mode numbers we're going to start
with one mode approximation then two
mode than three minutes and four mode
okay
just might work
and then surely it becomes perfect why
does it become perfect this is super
weird why does the approximation become
perfect with exactly 100 modes I have an
infinite series here
this is not a trick question because I
have exactly 200 increments right so
this is a purely numerical artifact
there's still all that crazy [ __ ] going
on
it's just that in this DX it's exactly
equal to the function value okay so
that's called aliasing so all of these
errors are being aliased out by my very
very clever choice of DX but if I change
my DX now this is dangerous because I
haven't actually tried this but if I
change my DX to 0.0001 I'm pretty sure
that those won't go away as M goes to
100 I'm pretty sure I'll keep having
some pretty bad disagreements between my
functions yeah that's that new equals
100 M equals 100 so you still get those
disagreements when I have the resolution
to see them okay and these will only get
kind of infinitesimally small as my
number of modes goes to infinity this
this phenomenon has a name where you get
this big ringing does anyone know what
this is called Gibbs phenomenon so this
is called Gibbs phenomenon where you get
this high frequency ringing near sharp
edges this is the same Gibbs from
physics pretty interesting
you could try any function here this was
just a function I cooked up
we could try let me get rid of this
crazy this so M equals 5 in increments
of 5 to 100 maybe 2 in increments of 2
to 100 so let's say that our function f
equals just sine of X what's going to
happen in this example
maybe let's see no it still takes a lot
of iterations because sine of X is not
periodic on 0 to 1 okay so let's try
sine of X times 2 pi perfect
one iteration yeah
I'm fighting with MATLAB here so I've
got a perfect agreement in one iteration
there's one last cool function I think I
can code up pretty quickly let me just
grab it from over here so this is a
sawtooth function okay big sawtooth
function looks a little weird but we're
gonna see how this does
okay we see that with very very few
iterations this thing converges to the
sawtooth pattern which is really nasty
ill-behaved okay there's so many
interesting things we can do with this
we have a lot of choices in front of us
okay so part of me wants to spend more
time thinking about Fourier series
because they're just cool so for example
in this equation is this an even or an
odd function odd function right so if I
pictured what will be happening back
here it would be kind of equal and
opposite sine waves so it's like
anti-symmetric or skew symmetric and so
if I looked at the coefficients a N and
B n what would you expect to happen I
would expect that all of my A's are
equal to zero and the only nonzero terms
are B's because I'm basically trying to
approximate an odd function I can only
do it with my science I can't possibly
do it with cosines or else I'd have
weird even function crap happening so it
for odd functions I can represent odd
functions purely using sine series
Fourier sine transform x' and for even
functions I can exactly represent them
with only the cosine terms these Fourier
cosine series and for general nasty
functions like that step function then I
actually would need both of them okay
there's four general functions I need
both sines and cosines but for special
even functions I can get away with just
cosine series for special odd functions
I can get away with just sine series
this is really quite important because
in the last lecture we had a series that
was just in terms of sine waves but sine
waves aren't enough sine waves are not
complete if we think about this vector
space analogy then each of these sine
waves of different frequencies as a
direction okay but if I only have the
sines alone I own
the space of odd functions if I just
have my co-sign directions alone I would
just be able to span the space of even
functions and the only way I can space
span the space of all possible functions
is to have both sines and cosines okay
so in the next lecture what we're gonna
look at we're gonna try more fourier
series we're gonna start looking at what
these coefficient values look like why
they decay to zero why this gets better
and better with higher N and we're gonna
generalize this to function spaces okay
thank you